All right, well.
Bye.
Whew.
Here's the craziest
thing about last night.
Like his body just--
It felt like home.
Dude, does this taste
skunked to you ?
No.
What does he do ?
Okay, we did
not get to that,
but according to Google,
like finance, maybe.
What'd you get into
last night ?
Nothing.
Actually, I got kind
of hammered.
God, I like,
miss him.
I'm gonna text him.
Oh,
you should wait.
No, the amazing thing
is that we're not playing games.
Oh my God.
( phone alert )
No idea who
that is.
How hard is it to open
a joint checking account ?
And this is for you
and your husband ?
Husband ?
I--
I guess, I guess.
I have a feeling.
Mm-hmm.
This is it.
This is my
wedding cake.
This place
is perfect.
Unless he's Jewish.
Whatever, it's my day,
right ?
You know what ?
There's one more thing
I'd like to take a look at.
You know what ?
I just--
I feel it.
I feel like Matt and I will
just be at peace here.
Yeah.
God.
You know what ?
I'm gonna call my boo-boo,
see what he's up to.
( phone ringing )
Hello ?
Hey.
Just at the cemetery,
thinking boutcha.
What are you thinking
for tonight ?
I'm literally
down for whatever.
Who is this ?
Uh, it's Amy.
We--we hung out last night,
I came back to your place.
Right, yeah.
Sorry, I think
I'm gonna take a pass
on us seeing each
other again.
Did I wear a bag ?
What a dick !
Ma'am, should
I stop digging ?
Yeah.
Wait.
What's your name ?
My name's Charles.
Amy Charles.
Keep digging.